ten machines really think for decades
we've been told that human-like
artificial intelligences around the
corner universe the giant electronic
brain I'm doing the talking that's the
most remarkable thing I've ever seen
we are still waiting but scientists are
making progress today thinking machines
can respond socially to human movement
and emotion no do not do that no I can
communicate in many of the ways that
people do don't I'll give it assistant
medical care
from mood elevating robots that respond
to human touch to systems that aid and
diagnosis have you been feeling tired
lately
yes can you bring your child to see the
doctor they can play soccer kind of
collaborate with us in the workplace we
might need to check your calendar to see
if he had any free time later today yes
earth and in space more of Jeopardy to
human champions going brain to brain
with a supercomputer named Watson and
recently this language savvy machine
captured the world's attention this
person is appointed by a testator to
carry out the directions and requests in
his will
Watson what is executor right same
category 1600 Watson who is Franz Liszt
Watson who is the church lady Watson
what is narcolepsy you are right I would
have thought the technology like this
was years away but it's here now I have
the bruised ego to prove it we've come
from this to this how will artificial
intelligence impact our lives in the
future
[Music]
good evening and welcome to the fourth
annual World Science Festival and to our
program tonight man-made Minds living
with Thinking Machines or as I like to
call it man-made Minds beyond the Roomba
as we saw on the video AI has been a
human obsession for much of the last
century it shows up all the time in our
imaginations and now it's showing up
increasingly in our daily lives so
tonight we'll explore how AI is
influencing our lives already and the
role of AI in the future what humanoid
skills from a robot can we expect one of
our panelists tonight Rodney Brooks
hopes that in the near future robots
will have get this the social skills of
a human eight-year-old the dexterity of
a six-year-old the language skills of a
four-year-old and the object recognition
of a two-year-old in other words soon
we'll be hearing robots saying I know
you are but what am i well playing rock
paper scissors so how far away are we
from that and how far are we from an
ardent artificial intelligence that can
solve a new problem
it hasn't been trained to solve an AI
that can be adaptive like like a
biological system like us how far are we
from an AI capable of autonomous
creation and invention can machines
think how good our machines at imitating
humans will look for answers tonight
each of our panelists is a leader in the
field of AI and has a different approach
to this challenge each focuses on a
different issue from behavior based
robotics to natural language processing
to integrate integrity of AI to
evolutionary robotics and they've even
brought some toys from the lab clearly
it's my very real pleasure not simulated
at all to introduce them to you Rodney
Brooks is the guy who invented the
Roomba but that's not all Rodney is the
Panasonic professor of Robotics emeritus
at MIT and for over a decade he directed
the MIT artificial intelligence
laboratory and then the MIT computer
science and artificial and then the MIT
computer oh I guess he
directed all of them he's a he's that
smart or maybe he directed one in a
parallel universe
he's a robotics entrepreneur he's
founder of iRobot who not only make the
Roomba but also robots who perform bomb
disposals rod recently founded heartland
robotics which aims to be at the
forefront of what Brooks sees as a
coming revolution in the way robotics
will be used in daily life particularly
how robots will be integrated into our
workplaces is it weird to stand there
while I'm talking about you and
third-person you can sit if you want
thank you um land robotics that sounds
to me like like a think tank for
Republican presidential candidates no
it's it's about manufacturing in the
heartland bringing manufacturing back
from China and and rod starred as
himself he did a very good job playing
himself in the 1997 Errol Morris movie
fast cheap and out of control named for
one of your scientific papers please
help me welcome Rod Brooks circuit
from rod to HOD HOD Lipson is a
roboticist who's created several
self-aware robots HOD is an associate
professor at Cornell University's School
of Mechanical and aerospace engineering
and computing an informational science
he's also director of the creative
machines lab there his focus is on
evolutionary robotics or biologically
inspired robots he's interested in
whether a computer can ultimately
augment or replace human invention let's
find out please help me welcome HOD
Lipson
computer scientists Eric Horvath's is a
distinguished scientist at Microsoft
Research
he's the immediate past president of the
Association for the Advancement of
artificial intelligence
Eric researches computational systems
that perceive learn and reason and he's
working on practical applications for AI
including designs for more natural
personal interactions with computers I
don't know about you I would love an ATM
that hugs me when I withdrawal please
welcome Eric Orbitz
okay if I say David Ferrucci you should
hit your buzzer and say who is the man
who brought jeopardy champs Ken Jennings
and Brad Rutter to their knees Dave is
the principal investigator for the
Watson jeopardy project Watson whom we
have over here as an avatar is a
computer system that managed to beat
Jennings and rudder Jeopardy's to
all-time champions in a televised
competition last February the Watson
research project was called deep QA
which is not a porn film about a I know
it is the follow-up to IBM's deep blue
project which you might remember
resulted in a computer chess champion
that won a six-game match against Garry
Kasparov in 1997 and Dave was just named
in IBM fellow so I think it's safe to
say he doesn't use a Mac please help me
welcome Dave Ruchi
rod let's start with you your work is
based on behavior based robotics what
does that mean well behavior based came
from looking at insects and deciding
that perhaps they were built out of lots
of little simple rules coupling sensors
two actuators so if an ant is walking
along and smells more pheromone on the
left take longer steps with the right
legs steers the ant towards the left and
then I hypothesized we hypothesize that
maybe animals higher animals were made
up of lots of simple little loops
connecting sensors to actuators and even
humans later you're gonna see people
talk about language and rationality my
deep hypothesis is that's not really
there it's all simple little rules and
if I may I want to show the audience I
think there's an audience out there but
I can't actually see you I want to show
you that you have little behaviors that
you don't have conscious access to so if
all of you could swing your eyes hard to
the right and then slowly and smoothly
move them to the left and I think what
you'll find is you can't move them
slowly and smoothly they jump from place
to place
but if you watch me I'm going to stand
over here just look at me and now as I
walk and you've got a target to look at
your eyes move smoothly from right to
left so you've got this little behavior
there that couples onto a target that
you can't access consciously but happens
underneath your conscious level but
that's how I try to build robots have
bits and pieces like that so it appears
that you brought some friends I did
today some old friends are they old how
old are they in robot she's just about
three months with a lot of hair how long
have you been working on this gentleman
this is this is one of my PhD students
robots this is domo aaron ed Singer
built Domo and like all robots in labs
it don't only operate during the PhD and
stop working the day that Aaron worked
so instead I'm going to show you a video
but I but I want you to look at the eyes
the eyes and the eyes are important for
communicate
at the subconscious level and there are
cameras behind those eyes and if we
could roll the first video we'll see
Aaron interacting with Domo and watch
Aaron's eyes as he interacts with Domo
can we have that video
no Domo is watching where Aaron is at
all times and Aaron keeps looking at
those eyes check whether download is
doing what he expects
[Music]
so deadliest looked at but to see
whatever Heron was and he's gonna follow
Aaron around as Aaron
this was actually work funded by NASA as
an assistant to an astronaut in the
space station DOMA is going to follow
where Aaron is and bring the traitor at
all times but I do want you to see how
but they keep looking into each other's
eyes knowing what's going on between
each other very loving okay maybe we can
finish the finish for that video
domo speaking to its saying some can
phrases but it's not really any any real
meaning to the phrases and what's the
purpose of that it's actually debugging
feedback for Aaron to know what's okay
but I want to show you something yes
okay um now you see my watch there yes
that how do I get your attention
I made this motion yes you looked at my
eyes to see where I was looking you look
down there you look back and forth this
eye interaction we use all the time and
if I show you this has happened this is
how to take a watch off now you smile to
get me a little a nonverbal feedback
that you understood then you just nodded
we didn't rehearse this we deliberately
didn't worry firstly I am a robot you
have programmed me yes no that's the
point humans aren't easy to control I
made you look where I wanted to and so
one of the things he did was was make
facial expressions and that gave me
feedback and if we could have the the
next video we'll see another robot
kismet which is the the icon of this
session making various facial
expressions
so kismet has lots of facial expressions
are the eyes the most important thing is
the most important and gaze Direction is
the most important cue if if someone's
looking off in the wrong direction when
you're talking to them you think they're
really weird you think maybe they're an
MIT undergrad or something like that now
now in the video with Aaron how does
Domo know where to look dolma has got a
face detection program and you're gonna
see more face detection later in the
session and then looks for eyes and
looks towards the eyes how does Aaron
know we'll look well we put eyeball
looking things over the cameras so that
Aaron knows that and this next video is
a naive subject who knew nothing about
the robot and we asked him to talk to
kiss MIT but we didn't tell him that
kismet actually doesn't speak English
doesn't understand a word he says but
you see the interaction worked pretty
well without without either side
understanding what this with what this
thing listen carefully
[Music]
like I almost lost it this week
so you see I did manage to program faith
she did exactly what what what kismet
did when I said I want to show you my
watch psychologist when you're creating
robots my students did and I did read a
lot of psychophysical literature and a
lot of psychology and all sorts of
medical literature to understand how the
pieces might come together to make this
sort of pre verbal pre rational
pre-linguistic interactions and I think
you have another video where the
conversation doesn't go so well
well you'll see some some more naive
subjects at different ages interacting
with the robot and maybe pushing things
a little further than you might think is
appropriate
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no no I think we have something on I
think there's something here between so
he just said it's like looking at me
creeped out she did which I can
understand I mean can you can you talk
about this uncanny valley theory when
robots creep us out yeah but the uncanny
valley is about about robots that look a
little too human but don't deliver on
the promise and this is actually a toy
that my company iRobot built a few years
ago with Hasbro and I never know what
but I never know what this baby's gonna
do when we switch it on but when we foot
I think you can see it there when we
first built it we actually had the eyes
being able to move right and left and
everyone thought it was Chucky and it
really scared yeah yeah let's let's give
her a bottle for a second well she
burped sometimes sometimes she does
something of the other end too
but there's two things here it's a
little weird it's not like a hundred
thousand assault okay
but I just want to end here you know we
see this device and for a little bit we
sort of think of it as a as a baby as a
person and you know we'll get shocked if
we do that's not right it's not right
that's not right the first days of
Elijah you know when he lies that came
out of this program where you people
could communicate with back in the 60s
and they started revealing secrets to
the program only to be disappointed to
learn that it wasn't a real psychologist
yeah so we it doesn't take much to draw
out our idea that there's an animal
being behind pretty simple mechanism in
this case how important is the cute
factor because that was kismet that we
saw right yes domo as a cousin that yeah
if we go back to if we go back to the
logo for the for the for this session
you'll see kismet eyes are very large
and so we measured that actually
amplified prosodic speech speech talking
cutely to it whoa and it was much more
in a robot with large eyes and small
eyes because babies have larger we think
maybe it's because babies have larger
eyes relative to their face and this
just drew out that natural prasat ik
behavior which by the way made it easier
for our algorithms to get the emotional
content of people's speech directed
towards kismet wait say that again with
when people react as if it's a child and
it's very cute and makes your algorithms
they they they they amplified the
prosody in their speech made up much
more emphasized which just made it
easier for our algorithms make sense
because the way we talk to a child is
clearer and slower than the way we exact
to an adult exactly now can you define
uncanny valley it's such a great term
you guys the whole week the uncanny
valley is is when the robot looks like
something but then doesn't quite deliver
and those one little clip in the
introduction the Einstein robot looks
like Einstein but doesn't really act
like Einstein and people get really
weirded out by that robot in person so
there's I did see George Bush shaking
its hand
so there's sort of there's this there's
this edge where something is cute enough
and human enough to be fun to interact
with and then it just gets creepy yes
where is kismet you see up there it
still looks like a machine right so you
don't get surprised when it does
something not quite right because we
know it's not a it's not a real flesh
and flesh sort of object so you look
very cute um did you ever name her this
is my real baby oh okay I'm sorry I
didn't so besides being super cute and
fun to watch and play with why are you
doing this what what do these what do
these robots mean for our future we're
trying to understand this this pre
verbal communication so that when we
have a device that we want to interact
with such as a robot in the factory it
becomes very easy to teach it you teach
it how to do a task the same way you
teach a person looking at their eyes
seeing where they're paying attention
knowing whether they're understanding
using the same sort of cues you don't
need to be an expert to program a robot
to do something quite complicated well
and it's interesting and fun it is
interests of science that's a good
Segway to you Dave because I think you
just said it's you don't need to be an
expert to program a robot to do
something complicated
oh it's like that okay because you did
something very very very complicated
right why why jeopardy
why did you tackle jeopardy well I think
when you when you look at a lot of
science fiction one of the things that
you know I think a lot about it starts
racket and we have Captain Picard or
Captain Kirk talk you know fluently
dialoguing with a computer and so often
so many of these things we imagine
humans being able to just start speaking
naturally to a machine and having that
machine understand and respond to answer
questions and it's been a dream of AI
for very long time but one of the real
challenges is that you know human
language is created by humans for humans
this
but computers had nothing to do with it
so now we bring computers in and we
think wow computers are powerful they're
fast we can get them to do really
complicated things how do we get them to
dialogue and speak in human human
language turns out to be very very a
very very difficult problem and jeopardy
helps us sort of push the technology
along jeopardy is something that
requires that the computer understand
what a questions asking about that it's
sort of read and study content try to
figure out what what the right answer is
by understanding language at some level
so it helps us drive that technology and
not just understanding content but if
you're familiar with game of Jeopardy
involves context sometimes they have
puns in the web there are their palms
and there is there's a lot of ambiguity
and antacid aspects of the of the
questions you know things that are not
spoken but sort of opaque references and
language in general it's very very
contextual so you have to understand how
words are used in different contexts to
try to get at the real meaning how long
did you work on Watson so it was about a
four year project a team at IBM research
about for about 20 people on average
over the four years and you know the
other thing I want to say about that
though is that you know we built on
technology an AI that has been in
development for decades really so it
wasn't just for example we started from
scratch in four years
there was parsing technology technology
for sort of dissecting the syntax and
the structure of natural language that
had been under development for four
decades
machine learning technology that has
been on development for decades also
we're using resources knowledge
resources that have been developed by
the community things like Wikipedia and
dictionaries need to sorry that have
been built by humans so what when you
see Watson apply this is the technology
that has really been built on years and
years of human effort um what is we have
a avatar of Watson here what does Watson
really look like under Watson's face I
guess which is a at least colorful you
know it's interesting when you contrast
it with some of Raji's work you know we
stood when we started with Watson we we
did not want to anthropomorphize it
because we
we wanted to focus on on the core
technology the technology of sort of
under trying to understand language and
answering the precise question answered
with precise answers and with
probabilities or confidences associated
with that and we really didn't want to
put a robot on stage but ultimately we
had to put something and we chose to put
something more abstract but of course
this is just what's in space Watson's
brain is about 10 refrigerators worth of
hardware so this is equivalent to about
you know six or seven thousand you know
desk you know powerful powerful desktop
computers so it's a lot of work going on
Watson's brain to try to just answer a
question and what's interesting is if
you compare that to to the human so Ken
Jennings and Brad Rutter got up there
and they have brains that sort of fit in
a shoebox and powered by a tuna fish
sandwich in a glass of water
you know Watson needed 80 kilowatts of
electricity and about 20 tons of
air-conditioning to compete at a similar
task and and Watson Suton couldn't walk
in and converse with you and tell jokes
whereas Ken and Brett could so the human
brain is actually quite quite remarkable
is Watson the world's first English
fluent database I wouldn't really think
of it that way I mean III don't know
exactly what you mean by English fluid a
to base but I do have a story to tell
you you know I was interviewed by a
radio show her radio show host from San
Francisco and was a live interview and
he asked me you know so so let me get
this right so you you have this database
so it's kind of like a spreadsheet table
and you put all the questions in one
column and you put all the answers in
the second column and then the clue
appears and Watson looks for that clue
and reads out the answer right no not
only didn't want to have the question
not only didn't have the answers didn't
even have the questions at a time they
had no idea what it was going to be
asked and the radio show host said well
then how do you do it I said exactly
so how do you do it exactly well you
know there are obviously you know really
a lot of challenges in there in fact I
wanted to share some with you if you
look at a few Jeopardy questions I'll
point out a few really interesting
challenges about natural language I
think they're gonna appear maybe up on
the screen yeah there you go so here was
a clue the the category was decorating
and includes if you're standing it's the
direction you should look to check out
the wainscoting anybody have any idea
what the answer is down very good you
know what's interesting about about this
question though is that you and asks for
a direction and if you think well gee
how would I tell the computer about what
a direction is and you can think well
you know there's north south east and
west or maybe I want a model direction
by you know mark telling you about all
the degrees are on a compass or maybe I
want to do is sort of you know behind my
back in front of my nose there's all
different ways to model the direction
and to think here's where the answers
are going to come from but let's look at
another Jeopardy clue this one is the
direction of threads in a fabric is
called this like the patterns of fiber
and wood the answer is actually grain so
if I had limited my limited myself or if
I had limited the computer to only think
about the directions that I could think
of and list them I wouldn't have I
wouldn't have imagined if the computer
wouldn't be able to connect very
different sorts of directions in
different contexts to the answer so
natural language is sort of hard when
you think about all the context in which
languages words are used and what they
might mean in those very very context so
how is Watson figuring out the meaning
what it does is it relies a lot on
reading lots of lots of content and
looking at how words are used in the
context so around other words and
computing probabilities likelihoods that
they would be used in the in in these
different contexts and not relying on
sort of strict databases that say these
are the five different directions and
that's it whatever it is
so there has to be a lot more flexible
with language if you will I think I have
another I have another one to look at
here so here's a link in blogs and
Treasury secretary chase just submitted
this to me just submitted to me this to
me for the third time guess what pal
this time I'm accepting it
that's the clue do you have any idea
what the answer is it's a bit a
resignation resignation other Jews what
is a resignation that's right so what is
the resignation you've got it right $200
so what what do you did you know this
Oracle fact not don't embarrass if you
did no no no no so you know how'd you
get it you got it because of the context
you thought well what kinds of things
are typically submitted exactly and
moreover so you started thinking your
head what kind of things are submitted
what kinds of things are submitted by a
Treasury secretary when old presidents
involved will see worth even mentioning
and you could sort of would infer that
it's a resignation Watson actually does
something similar contrary to sort of
popular beliefs not all the answers are
exactly spelled out anywhere in the
content so connecting the answers to the
language is not like looking something
up in a database so Watson will read
lots of text and it will compute
probabilities about what's likely an
answer in this context and that will
give it a clue and then it'll try to
sort of prove it or get evidence that
that's in fact the case but when I gave
this talk to a sixth-grade they used
that context and they came up with a
very different answer their answer was
[Laughter]
so so clearly they didn't know that they
didn't know the history and we're using
the context to try to answer to try to
answer the question so this is clearly a
difficult task have soon there have been
blips along the way that Watson has
evolved has he gotten stuff wrong oh
yeah so Watson we has many many
algorithms in it and we train those
algorithms and got Watson to study and
refine them over time how do you get
Watson to study your you know TV a
no-face you know an analyzing video and
learning from from that is actually a
huge opportunity for AI but with Watson
we gave it all kinds of books plays
encyclopedias dictionaries the Sorai
and got it to analyze all that stuff
news articles and what have you and
throughout it you know
analyze that and understand it and then
when the question would come in relate
what it could infer from that to what
it's reading in the question but it
wasn't always I didn't always perform
perform really well out of the box I
mean couldn't day one couldn't obviously
be Ken or Brad and it has lots of
growing pains so here are some examples
of Watson's early years when Watson was
under development the American Dream
decades before Lincoln Daniel Webster
spoke of government made for made by and
answer the tooth in anybody anybody know
people very good Watson so this again
gives you a sense that you know Watson
always wasn't always as smart as it may
be today we give you a another one
because these are just too fun to pass
up
in 1994 25 years after this event a
participant said for one crowning moment
we were creatures of the cosmic ocean
anybody heading on the moon excellent
Watson what is the Big Bang so not a lot
of people around during the Big Bang to
comment on it here's another one for you
let's see an exclamation point was
warranted for the ends of this in 1918
World War 1 Watson I need an exclamation
points ends a sentence in any year
really so but you can see there was
clearly work to do and try to make
Watson smarter and one last one and only
because it's just again too funny to
pass up a very early version of Watson
this Frenchman was the father of
bacteriology anybody be fast or very
good and Watson
delicious
did you guys did it make you guys laugh
when he did that or were you guys like
alright well there's a little laughter
and there's a little that was both
alright are you guys ready for some oil
I think we're gonna see Watson apply
little jeopardy yeah we're gonna play a
few clues the challenge of panelists and
what's gonna happen in it what's gonna
happen in this in this game is we're
gonna play we actually win this money
you know I'm not paying it but we so
what's gonna happen in here is we're
gonna play a clue and then I'm gonna
explain a little bit about how Watson
works Oh sort of look under the covers a
bit on how its algorithms work at least
at a very high level and what you're
looking at is a Jeopardy Jeopardy grid
which you're probably all familiar with
and at the top is Watson's answer panel
so when Watson picks a clue the clue is
going to come out we're gonna compete to
answer it as soon as the clue I'll read
it so as soon as I'm done reading these
guys will get an opportunity to try to
buzz in and at least try to beat Watson
to the punch there and but Watson will
as soon as Watson can figure out its
answer based on reading the clue you'll
see its answer come up in that answer
panel but it'll be blurred so you won't
know until we see who ends up winning
the buzzer so Watson please you know go
ahead pick a clue EU the European Union
for 200 so each year the EU selects
capitals of culture one of the 2010
cities was this Turkish meeting place of
cultures
looks like Rodney Brooks do not screw
this up in the name of all mankind
Rodney what do you have Istanbul let's
see I think that's correct why can't
like a question what is this symbol what
is this the Guerrera Watson what did you
have
what is this temple very good in fact
with 84 percent over 84 percent
confidence okay
this other answer is excellent rod so
let's um let's uh let's you know this is
the first time I'm actually feeling the
fear from AI
you you weren't there when we were
playing the game live and I had to sit
there and I was I was nail-biting trust
me so well you know one of the things as
I mentioned earlier is just you know
jeopardy asks about all kinds of things
and that breadth of domain the fact that
it can use all kinds of varied language
and ask about a huge number of things
from substances to people to countries
the audience the places the diseases the
phenomenons is just this huge list and
you get this what we call a very long
tail phenomenon which is if you were you
really been trying to build a databases
and anticipate all the possible
questions you can ask where would you
focus there's just too many things so
that's why Watson had to really learn
how to analyze and understand the huge
volumes of language of natural language
content that's that's out there so why
don't we when we to look at how Watson
works on the inside so this is sort of
peeling back you know opening to the
hood if you will and Watson gets the
question and when it gets it it tries to
sort of break it down and analyze it you
know so the way you might do in high
school or college you know I should say
probably high school grammar schools is
dissect the question if you go out what
are the parts of parts of speech where's
that where's the verb where's the
subject where's the object prepositional
phrase you do all that Watson tries to
do that too with with algorithms called
parsers and then they look at and try to
identify things semantically like what
are the places who are the people what
are the events and how are they're
related and then effort does that after
it does that it generates many many
searches based on what it things have
understood the questions asking about
and from there it generates many
possibilities so hundreds of
possibilities so in this case Brussels
or Turkey or sorry you know so it
generates many many possibilities and
for each one it goes and says what if
this were the right answer can I prove
it if you will so it collects a lot more
what we call evidence and then it scores
that evidence weeds and says yes this
this paragraph here or this passage over
the year seems to suggest that this is
the right answer and it computes
probabilities likelihoods right that
that passage that it read or that
document read supports that as an answer
and it does that and then it has to
weigh all those confidences scores based
on all those pieces of evidence and it
combines those weights and it gets
what's called an
evidence profile that ever Evans profile
gives us a sense of how well the
evidence at read supports the different
answers and whichever answer had more
support from these different dimensions
like document support or logical
justification or popularity or time or
our type match whichever one so to have
the most support from from from the
majority of these dimensions of evidence
is the one that gets the highest
probability in this case instant poll
for 84% let me ask you as you were you
were working Watson for years did this
process decrease in time was was that we
got better and you mean at the time of
the tape Watson to answer yes the time
he comes well when we when we first
started and when watch would run like on
a single computer like on a single CPU
it would take two hours to go through
that process to answer a single question
which would make for a very boring
Jeopardy game so we ended up had us
having to scale it out on 2880 cores
alright so when you buy a computer today
you know it's dual cores you've two of
them sort of two thousand eight hundred
eighty and 15 terabytes of memory it's
about five thousand times more memory
that you typically have this is why
Hazel's biggest chances why he's as big
as he is so let's go let's do another
let's do another clue yeah um so see if
you guys can beat Watson to the punch
again we didn't we didn't we didn't do
it in rehearsal we've never taken right
well well I gave you some tips in
rehearsal though so you're obviously
using them so let's see Watson please
choose a piece of shoes another clue
classic literature for 1000 so the first
person mentioned by name and the man in
the iron mask is this hero of a previous
book of the same author Oh Watson won
this and what a surprise so
anybody know anybody knows anybody even
try didn't even see one of those things
light up so none of you wanna wager I
guess I don't even know which book oh
that's excellent you just set me right
up there so
so in fact Watson what's your what's
your answer who is dirt onion who is
d'Artagnan that's right that's the right
guys probably new and one and one of the
things like you know rowdy really set
this one up because one of the things
that has to happen is that first Watson
looks at this question figures out you
know it's asking for a hero but the hero
of why and it's actually of a previous
book by the same author so Watson has to
decompose the question and it has to
find and it has to say well first I've
got to figure out what the previous book
was and it generates a new question and
it goes out and uses that algorithm that
I described to find the answer to that
it's a bunch of possibilities the one
that believes the most in his three
musketeers takes that and formulates and
looks at now the question was the hero
of the three musketeers and it uses
again the same set of programs to try to
answer that and it actually gets
d'Artagnan so that's exactly how it
breaks that down which is how the human
you thought gee I have to get that first
and that's exactly how a good the same
algorithm answer other kinds of
questions do they have to be formulated
in this particular Jeopardy form no we
try to do we try to make it as general
as it can as general as we could
obviously for jeopardy you know that was
that sort of you'd have to say it as a
sentence but if you came in and you said
who or what it would also respond to
that David maybe you can comment a
little bit on the amount of human
engineering it had to go into the system
for example even creating those classes
popularity location well that's a great
great question marathi invention is
earlier you know there's no one
algorithm inside watson that really
knows how to answer questions there's
lots of many many different algorithms
and the way we developed those
algorithms was we started you know off
with just very few of them and we looked
at where watson failed and we thought
gee where do we need to make Watson's
warren do we may need to make it smarter
understanding expressions of time so we
need to make it smarter and
understanding puns and what a pun
relationship is so we need to make it
smarter understanding geography things
like that and different humans engineers
on the team would develop these
algorithms and sort of throw them in to
Watson
and then Watson would use statistical
machine learning to figure out how to
balance them to what extent do was one
contribute to the answer or another so
it was a lot of human engineering that
went in there but we tried to make those
algorithms that really as general as we
could and with jeopardy provided that
breadth of the domain that really drove
that generality up which was which was a
good thing
now you mentioned the evidence the
dimensions of evidence so while we would
though if those various algorithms
different people would notice it needs
to get smarter in time I have an idea
how to make it smaller a time someone
else geography I have an idea how to
make it smarter that someone else at
classification I have an idea on how to
make it smarter at that and did all
those ideas boil down into mathematics
is that how they were implementing
linguistics and mathematics language of
mathematics and we'd trade all those
algorithms and before you know we had
hundreds of these and what we did in
order to understand what was going on in
other words in order to communicate back
to the humans in this case developers
but ultimately users we would group
those those algorithms into these
categories so those categories you see
like time and popularity those are names
CAD words we name them and we groove to
those algorithms onto something that
made sense to us the to the to the
developers or potentially to a human
user to you and I tonight in fact there
you see an example now we have different
dimensions of evidence we started to
adapt Watson to of the medical space and
in fact oh I'm sorry yeah that's where I
want to be and you see that question you
know this disease can cause you Vitus
and pit in a patient with a family
history of arthritis presenting circular
rash fever and headache so this is an
actually question that's used to test
residents freshly-minted doctors and
many of the same algorithms but now he
adapted them to to a new domain looking
at symptoms and family history
information and we did the same thing we
took those algorithms we now adapted for
the medical domain and we named the
dimensions of evidence we knew would
matter to people using Watson trying to
understand why did they come up with a
70 cent 76 percent confidence in Lyme
disease which is in fact in this case
the right answer so you could look at
the evidence profile and say wow it
really liked the findings though or the
lab reports or it really liked on the
demographics or the exposure and you
could drill into there and actually see
the language the
graph the evidence the textbooks and the
and the things that it read to come up
with that confidence for Lyme disease do
you have any more questions I think we
have do we have any more I don't think
so
oh we do we have one more question no
that was one more oh there we go let's
go okay so medicine for 800 medicine for
800 so on the medical theme streptococci
caused this childhood fever
characterized by a bright red rash and
high temperature Horvitz is coping like
crazy but he was buzzing in too soon but
I'll give you a chance anyway why don't
you go ahead now you're a medical doctor
right scarlet fever is in fact the right
answer so Watson what did you have
what is scarlet fever scarlet fever with
quite sure about it as well with
ninety-eight percent on precision that
was my last question you guys actually
did pretty good I think I want to point
out though when I was watching how many
people saw the Jeopardy match a good
number of people yeah it was it was
riveting and when I was watching it in
the beginning the sort of Luddite
humanists part of me was so rooting for
Brad and Ken but when they would show
you guys in the audience because it took
place at IBM obviously Watson cannot fly
first-class to the studios of Jeopardy
and when they would cut to you guys I
realized Watson is a completely human
creation Watson is full of however 25
people working for four years you guys
were brought to tears by his victory
absolutely absolutely and so it made me
sort of realize and absolutely I mean it
was a very emotional experience it was a
nail-biting game was emotional for me
and for the entire team and there were
there were tears but the other point is
I made earlier is this you know Watson
represents building on the work of
actually so many scientists engineers
for decades really well
Watson's what is he doing now sitting
there smugly
so Eric where are we on building an AI
system that combines all of this stuff
multiple kinds of intelligences from
from natural language processing to
social interaction oh I should start
just by saying that since being a very
very young boy I was mystified by
thinking and reflection like many of you
probably are that that all continues to
this day and I started out and continued
to look at exploring fabrics of I said
rationality how do you learn from data
how do you make decisions under
uncertainty what are some principles
what's the aerodynamics of intelligence
and I think that kind of work is very
important and you saw how machine
learning for example just was with David
mentioned apply deeply to the success of
Watson but in recent years we've been
thinking more about what it is to be
human we're not just learners we're not
just decision makers we see we here we
interact socially and so some of the
more recent research we call innovative
AI and that we're trying to take those
fabrics as kind of nurturing substrate
but we're adding in various competencies
how do you combine natural language
machine vision speech recognition face
recognition face identification even
principles of conversational discourse
and trying to layer them into various
kinds of prototypes and I'll show you
one right now this is actually a
personal assistant that lives by my door
at Microsoft Research it's calling upon
evidence or learned insights about my
behavior over almost a decade it knows
how to prioritize email coming into by
urgency it understands how long it'll be
until I'm back given where I was last
seen on the corporate network or in the
world through GPS to my office it makes
predictions under a certainty even how
long a conversation an impromptu one
will last in my office if someone comes
up and wants to sort of work with me
so let's go ahead and take a look at at
the personal assistant
Jetix ago okay okay yes are you Dan and
Paul yes
I'm this virtual admin I know he has a
meeting scheduled with you but he's late
from his previous meeting in building 34
he's no longer on his laptop so I expect
we'll be back in ten minutes or so
Oh we'll come back in a minute okay I'll
make sure to let him note with your
attorneys all right so he's Jeff now
when I returned to my my first my office
this system actually recognizes my face
and then gives me a quick update who is
there I also get email from the
assistant about what's going on by the
way I should say that that we scanned in
my admin Andrea that's who you see there
she's a little bit in the uncanny valley
at the current phase of her existence
but but Andrea unfortunately fabulous
admin just went off the Peace Corps and
it is that is now in Haiti so I still
have a little piece of her working with
working by my office daihlia here let me
say that so this system actually even
looks at my busy calendar and has
learned over eight years as to which
meetings I will attend or not attend
even if they're on my calendar by all
the properties community has who's
attending the meeting who who asked who
invited me to the meeting whether I said
yes or no do you like and who you don't
like use all that out believe it or not
and it sort of reveals it in subtle ways
at times so yeah this moto knows how
busy I am
what's the cost of interruption at any
moment and let's take a look at what
happened with over here with rich rich
who showed up to see me one day hello
are you looking for Erica yes Erica's
busy working on a project at the moment
if it's urgent that you speak with them
right now you could interrupt them would
you like to go in now no it's not urgent
okay his calendar shows that he's fully
booked today come I'm not sure but I
don't think he'll be attending the
meeting on his calendar today at 4 or
bottom I could pencil you in them
wouldn't it work for you yes that's good
great it's someone you didn't like and
she just said no way Jose I take into
account who is it talking to it does my
phone I should say I should say that
several years ago we also have a system
that prioritizes email their urgency and
a few years ago we weren't erasing the
priority note when we forwarded it so
someone said I see that you gave very a
very low urgency score on her mail oh
that's ok we fixed that problem by
making sure when you forward an email we
erase the urgency score on the email so
there are some interesting privacy and
social issues that come up with these
systems let me just say that another
concept that comes up a lot we hear
about is that and I think it was in the
abstract for this session is that
computational intelligence sometimes
thinks very differently than human
intelligence and that's true quite a bit
in fact we built medical diagnostic
systems years ago and these systems
could ask the best questions next and
make recommendations as the tests but
doctors couldn't figure them out so we
had to slow them down and be more
human-like in some of the way we're
building systems components that reason
about human emotion what what kind of
things will surprise us even what kinds
of items I might forget so we have a
model of human memory that predicts
landmarks in memory the kind of thing
that you and your college roommate will
remember together when bill dropped or
whatever it was and you know you share
landmarks you also can reason about what
people might forget and here's an
example of something the system I
thought my assistant thought I might
forget when I walked up to it and
recognized me and wanted to fill me in
let's roll the last segment
hello Jaime Rick I don't have any new
messages for you but just so you know
the meeting with Peter Duesberg at
pendulum conference room 4,800 catch me
later my fine and you can read about
that work because publish that at the
Amish conference in April just brand new
work on memory models did you actually
program her to say catch you later that
was programmed by one of the developers
right now someday we weren't actually
we're actually working on called
crowdsourcing by recording with what's
going on with people we want to also
note what failed and have the failures
sent off to Mechanical Turk for example
and crowd-sourced where are lots of
people out in the world fix it with a
very simple language and come up with
different ways of responding and we're
curious as to what comes out of that
interesting experiment so do you think
we're all going to have computerized
personal assistants in our future well I
do think that there's a very strong
likelihood that we will rely more and
more on computation computational
intelligence in our daily lives in a
variety of ways you know I like to think
long term that we'll all have these
personal coaches that actually work with
us to understand procrastination or a
tendency to do such that understand that
we would love to go to this Saturday
evening event that so and these friends
will be in town and then arranging a
recommendation for a great night out of
the town thinking about where I might
have my next meal during a cross-country
trip knowing that I'm hungry at the
moment and on and on that's that's
possible quite possible I also think
that our grandchildren won't be fazed at
all when they walk into an airport and
are much richer looking avatar will say
are you guys all together and you're
Zachary right you're okay that bag is
awfully too big for this for that for
the plane right now and it's just
interacting in a natural conversational
way with with you places like that
we'll also need to have innovative AI to
really solve problems like autonomous
driving vision context awareness
understanding rules of the game so
innovative AI is really the the kind of
set of techniques and methods
that will on top of these deeper fabrics
that we'll bring into the world that
will touch our lives I think directly
you're also working on an application to
use AI in medical right so medical
diagnosis has been one of the with one
of the earliest challenge problems and
early successes of artificial
intelligence research starting back in
there in the early 60s and even late 50s
the famous work of Lillian lusted and so
on these days we were already to the
point where we the best diagnosis in the
world can be done by machines typically
even taking on the nuances of patient
symptomatology what you see when you
work to talk to a patient we're
combining some of the best expert models
with that kind of platform that
conversational platform you just saw to
create new kinds of experiences for
triage for example in lesser developed
countries where there might not be the
resources to have a human doctor around
now I'm gonna roll a clip now showing
you we call the medical Bayesian kiosk
Phase II refers to the probabilistic
methods the probability public reason
going on inside the the mind of this
intelligence but watch for how the
system recognizes the patient and the
caregiver understands how to ask each
one questions in different ways to get
at the symptoms and you'll see that even
the eye contact is represented by a red
dot where the avatar is looking at any
moment and you'll see next to the avatar
a knowledge base that represents
pediatric healthcare for a particular
chief complaint so let's roll that last
video segment hi thanks for coming to
the triage kiosk I am in touch with the
best doctors in the world are you here
for your child or yourself so how can I
help you
oh no sorry to hear that
hi there what's your name and how old
are you so five years old right yeah
almost six
okay six years old have you felt
nauseous I'm sorry has your child been
vomiting at all no okay so let's see has
there been a fever slight have you been
feeling tired lately
yes let's see how about abdominal pains
these no I've been to conflating the
world has your timing been hurting yes
oh I'm really sorry I hope it will feel
better as soon okay considering
everything you've told me I'd like to
schedule an appointment with the doctor
just to be sure however not to worry I'm
not that concerned at this point I will
say that that robot had more feeling
than many of the people in the emergency
room
well they don't even say I'm sorry when
you say you have diarrhea you know when
we show this this the system to some
people that the reaction sometimes is
wow it's remarkably caring and that
often brings up this reflection that I
have which is what are the ethics and
future directions with how we work with
computers that show emotion especially
in the early days of AI let's say the
next 25 years before they really feel
emotion we saw from rod you know systems
that were showing quite a bit of emotion
we know they really can't feel yet
they're not conscious I don't know where
well where do we say that
well well hang on a second I mean and
Hobbs will tell us a little bit more
about awareness and self-reflection here
but my sense is that by system right now
is not feeling deep sadness or care when
it works with into like a human being
would when it works with the patient the
little boy Marvin and his mom Minnie
so I have to say that I often have
reflected that maybe some day before
these systems are feeling and that might
be a very long time before they do the
way we think they are per least the the
implications do we need a surgeons
general
morning that says you know warning this
is an Avatara it's not really feeling
this right now but I think that gets
back to the uncanny valley actually if
it's not authentic then you do suffer
from this uncanny valley because you
expect more and then your expectations
aren't even even but even if we had the
most incredibly rendered emotion it can
even be like you know right out of
Casablanca if it's really just a
computational algorithm that's not as
deep as the ones we're running let's say
right now will we actually be running I
believe that we're that the the magic of
our mind is computational and
mathematical at the core so what now
humans have to wear a sign when they're
not authentic also good point so so let
me let me understand this
are you Eric saying that that you think
there will come a time when robots
actually feel and don't just simulate
feelings seamlessly so can I say that I
think we have existence proofs right on
this we have existence proofs right on
the stage and in the audience I mean as
I focused my whole my entire life on
what thinking was the more it became
clear to me that's likely to be based in
foundations of computation the more
awesome and astounding that hypothesis
became almost magical what about our
minds is computation and I think many
people in the audience might say most of
it
milla biology here and there to
understand what's going on but it's
quite likely in my mind that that the
the beauty and the wonders of mind is
based in the in the foundations of
computation so yes I do believe that not
only is it happening now on the stage
and in the audience but someday we'll be
able to recreate some of that kind of
thing and that is called
the long strong artificial intelligence
vision strong AI versus weaker notions
of AI just expand on that by the way
widely I've been talking about this for
debating about this for many but no but
I'm actually gonna take it
it's not a debate it's well it's not
necessary computation but I think we as
scientists think of ourselves as
machines where a bunch of molecules
which feel interact lawfully you know
there's laws about how the molecules
interact I think in medical school when
you were learning about how various
molecules drag molecules glommed under
something they didn't say oh and then
the soul into these it was all about Van
der Waals forces and how that happened
so we built out of this stuff which is
mechanism it may be a different sort of
stuff than silicon but the strong layer
happens hypothesis is that both sorts of
stuff can produce the same end result
and in fact the AI people will say that
a Turing machine which is a foundational
abstraction abstract machine which
represents all of computing as we know
it really could represent any kind of
intelligence if it was computational I
often have thought when I reflect and
and talk to myself you know styrofoam
balls rubber bands pipe cleaners if put
together right to do computation could
simulate Who I am right now
it's a matter of the actual algorithms
running on this substrate that's
important I think if you if you don't
agree you know if you're trying to do AI
you don't agree with that then it's
going to be a problem because I think we
give each other souls you think what we
give each other souls I extreme you I
you know he's a but he's a bag of skin
full of biomolecules but I interact with
him at a different level in that because
I attribute humaneness to a my
anthropomorphizing
I think
I think faith is asking you whether you
know whether there's a soul here do you
do you think that so so let's say that
technology will create could create a
robot that looks and acts exactly like a
human right do you think that there is
something essentially different that
real humans possess okay so when I
interact with or perceive another agent
you know whether it be a computer or a
human I don't feel I'm in the position
ultimately to judge that I feel I'm a
better position to judge myself but
ultimately as Rodney just said he's
anthropomorphizing you know who knows
make a comment I many of my colleagues
in AI I believe go into the field
because they they find the prospect that
the answer to a question is yes to be
astounding and they will do tedious
research to just see if they can change
the probability either way what are you
really answering yes to I guess you say
yes there is a soul yes that that that
know that that computation mathematical
principles accountants I've seen might
explain everything it's so astounding to
sit here and think that that might be
true that even changing the
probabilities on either side of X I know
if the answer is no there's almost no
point in doing this I don't buy that so
so first of all I mean I think that one
could you know so I agree with you in
principle that you could sit there and
you could say look everything could be
ultimately mccanna we could understand
that everything that we experience as a
machine in some form but I mean I think
answering this question is not essential
for building AI systems it just simply
isn't I mean I could build AI systems
that are very useful that do medical
diagnoses that help you do whatever and
I just never have to address this
question at all right so I've in my life
I viewed the fabulous and exciting
applications that we built would it be
in healthcare for predictions of like
readmissions for example to hospitals or
traffic prediction
what's happening over the long-term in
traffic in an area these are all very
exciting but what's really deeply
powering it up for me is the actual
answers to the deeper questions and I do
the applications that spin off as
exciting on the path well so there's
there's a deep philosophical question I
think we're gonna grapple with for a
long time and I think when we get to
that point where you see a machine
behaving very much like a human we're
gonna have to sit down and say what do
we do with this you know do we give it
Human Rights and you know so or do we
turn around to humans and say you better
start acting smarter and this whole
comes down to specialness I think you
know we this was the problem with the
earth not being the center of the
universe God had made the earth for us
and then that got taken away by the non
earth centric model of the universe we
were no longer so special then when
Darwin came along we were not separate
from the animal kingdom we were no
longer so special by the way religion
has survived these these these
challenges to the non-specialists but I
think we're getting to the same point
here that we're worried about a loss of
specialists when deep blue beat Kasparov
you mentioned that in the introduction
Kasparov said well at least it didn't
feel happy that I beat me because he
still had that special people ask me
about you know the you know you know we
wrote some algorithms some computer
programs to deal with puns and the way
we did this was we looked at what does a
human how does a human look at these
words and associate a pun relationship
and we identified these pun
relationships and we program into the
computer and what the computer knack can
do now is predict when a human would
identify a pond but the computer doesn't
find them interesting or funny or
anything else the computer just
identifies with we as humans consider
puns right so there's a very very clear
separation there I programmed the
computer to predict a human behavior
you'd the computer doesn't feel but
there I'm not saying that some point
that's gonna blur I mean that may end up
blurring but and ultimately we'll sort
of face that decision I think will be an
interesting time certainly I don't think
we're there yet
going to pause this because God can
speak to the consciousness and
self-awareness I do want to say you know
it may not be essential for for you guys
to probably these questions but as a
layperson I think it's provocative and
fascinating to ask you sort of the
thoughts that go through your minds as
you create this so haad not to give you
short tripped you have created
self-aware robots what is self-awareness
means so you know self-awareness is a
very big word consciousness big concept
so we're really trying to dis making
machine is to make machines that create
a a self-image 8 a perception of
themselves what they are as opposed in a
model and an image something that they
can use to make predictions to learn
about the world and it's part of our of
a broader research agenda to to
basically take a different perspective
on how to make AI and that is instead to
program it to breed it let me explain
that a little bit so you know in many of
these projects that we've seen there's
there's a huge team of engineers
involved in in creating there lots of
programmers many years and a lot of
specialized knowledge and and you just
heard that you know if if you need to
deal with puns suddenly you go and you
have to program a special thing to deal
with puns you need to deal with this
it's a lot of a lot of engineering and
that is a problem if you want to really
make something that can handle
unforeseen situations can handle things
that that you don't know in advance and
you can't set aside all this huge
manpower to program so the part is we're
taking is to say okay let's just breathe
these machines let's have a set of
machines start off knowing nothing or
knowing very little some very basic
knowledge and we'll let them experience
the world we'll let them interact with
each other and will simulate a process
of Darwinian evolution well let these
machines interact with each other with
each other
those that do better than others get to
reproduce we copy them with small
variations and
they don't reduce themselves well
sometimes we do this in physical
realities the machines actually build
other machines but in the in simulation
we can do that a lot faster so we put
them in this a in this big gaming
simulator if you like they all compete
with each other and after let's say
thousands or millions of generations of
millions of machines you get machines
that can actually do interesting things
and what's interesting to us about this
is that this is a very hands-off process
we don't need to actually have
developers sit down and program all
these things they kind of learned from
their experience and I think you know
this is the kind of controversial
question but in the really long term if
we really want to have AI be able to do
things that we cannot program it to do
we don't even know how we don't know
what needs to be programmed that's
really the only way to to make it happen
can we see so yeah so before we before
we show that let me explain a little bit
of what we're gonna see there so one of
the ideas behind this process of
evolution is this idea of self
Wallington machines they'll learn from
their experience and create its self
image that they use to predict what's
going to happen and this is an example
of a very simple robot this robot
doesn't look like a human at all it's
actually kind of spider looking robot
and it's going to have a few brief
interactions with with the world and
it's going to try to create to form an
image of itself let's see what happens
so this robot you'll see that it has
four legs but in fact this robot doesn't
know that it has four legs it just does
some moves its motors and creates
sensing sensations as here it's forming
gradually forming itself images as you
can see it's it's a it's a it actually
has no clue what it looks like it's
beginning to form a self image that
contains four legs it's beginning to
realize it has four legs and this is
already the sixteenth out of sixteen
trials it's pretty much figured out what
it looks like now this is a very simple
self image it's a kind of stick figure
but you can use
at self-image this this stick figure to
figure out how to walk and here it's
learning how to walk with its self-image
if you like it's learning how to walk in
its imagination and then it carries out
that walking around that you were hoping
that's going to develop an evil spider
Ewok and instead it has this lame way of
mochi but when you look at this you have
to remember that this machine was not
programmed to walk nor did it have a
model of itself nor did it do trials of
walking before so the idea here is that
it evolved the self image and used that
to figure out how to walk and of course
to test this to see if it really can
adapt we remove the leg off this robot
that's very sad I know but we put it
back on and you can see here the
dynamics changed and therefore the self
image has changed it took about a day
and then the robot learned how to limp
without the leg if you look closely you
can see that you didn't quite lose a leg
internally just made it short and here
you can see the robot moving without a
leg now
this is perhaps not the best way to move
without a leg but again you have to
remember that this robot was not
programmed to move in this kind of case
of damage there was no sensor that said
lay came off switch to plan B it's the
the leg came off therefore the dynamics
change therefore the self perception
changed and therefore it behaved in a
different way and you know I think that
if we really look in the long term
there's no escape but to really let
these machines develop the own
intelligence rather than programmed them
if we really want to get into the kinds
of human level intelligence that we
really after anything that starfish did
surprise you well certainly that way of
moving forward wasn't what I had in mind
and it's it's it's kind of interesting
to see what I think we always find it
fascinating when you don't program the
machine to do something and it does it
on its own accord there is something
really inspiring in that moment and I
think that's you know
the more you program it to do something
the less exciting it is when it actually
does exactly what you said because you
kind of you told it the answer when it
comes it up on its own I think it's very
exciting well that's kind of more of a
statement about so the the the the
distance between the abstraction that
you built for that for the machine and
what it ultimately ended up with as a
result so it's almost uh a blindness
that you have the pet you can't you can
imagine the pathway for example Watson
leads a tremendous amount of programming
but when it got a question we had no
idea ultimately how it answered that
question whether or not it would get her
right or wrong but of course we could we
understood the algorithms we rode and we
could go do the trace and figure out you
know how it got there but it was always
a surprise because we couldn't draw the
path was complicated enough that we
couldn't draw the path this brings up a
really interesting challenge problem for
artificial intelligence as the systems
get more and more sophisticated they
often do reason in ways that are very
unnatural for we're natural refers to
human thinking and we might want to work
with these systems and collaborate
therefore these systems need to explain
themselves with clarity learn how to
talk to people so that we can sort of be
partners in problem-solving and and
actually you've run into that chatter
right so that's this really interesting
kind of the second half of the story so
so I know we have this robot and it's
basically moving around it's sensing and
it's creating a model an image of its
experiences and so let's take this
algorithm out of the robot and connect
it through another system and see what
kind of model it creates in that other
system and and let's let's try it out so
we try it out on on the different system
actually I want to show this system over
here this is right here we have a what
is called a double pendulum it's the
same algorithm exactly okay in in in the
in example we saw we saw with the robot
it was an algorithm that actuated the
motors and sense the the tilt angles of
the of the of the robot here which we
are applying it to this double pendulum
and we have a double pendulum is
basically a pendulum thats hanging off
another pendulum so it's a kind of crazy
device
and we'll let the robot basically poke
this thing in different ways and watch
it move and and it's a really crazy
device let me show you how it works okay
it's kind of it's very non periodic it
goes it it swings in different ways very
difficult to predict so the Machine
looks at this and watches it for a day
and pokes at it and looks at in
different ways and thinks about it and
it took eight eight quad core machines
32 cores and after a day it spits out
one thing that it Lord force equals mass
times acceleration that's what it
learned from this machine and from
watching this and and experimenting with
this and then it spit out a couple of
other truths it found out that the
energy in this thing the total kinetic
energy and potential energy are constant
of course it didn't say that in those
words but he gave a formula which
happens to be the stating that fact and
the conservation of momentum all kinds
of interesting things that took people a
long time to discover so why do you
think it took so long to get to Newton
and even took him long time during his
life to figure these things out some of
these basic things about mass and
acceleration in force well it's you know
we this is often compared to Newton and
I think when we look back we have to
remember that Newton didn't just
discover F equal Ma what he really did
is is invent calculus an event inventing
calculus is essentially a new language
that allowed him to formulate these
things so the really interesting thing
here is not just discovering new truths
by observations but also discovering a
language that allows us to to represent
these new findings and that's what we
really want the AI to do not just to
learn but to discover the language in
which to report and to assign the
significance while your program discover
the formula to know what the meaning the
meaning or what to do absolutely why it
was important essentially you're saying
that that algorithm put into the machine
hooked up to the double pendulum
covered a new law a new law to it right
a biological exactly is does your mind
then go to how many new things about the
universe can computers help us discover
right so exactly that what what else is
there to discover and I think we're
we're at the point now in in science
where there we're being overwhelmed with
data there's a lot of data coming in and
we could use machines that could look at
all this data and try to find you that
right no really right I mean I don't
machines do a lot of that you know when
we actually change this thing we
published this we started getting emails
from people saying I have a lot of data
please find something in my old Johnny
Carson thing Carnac the magnificent
where you have your you're sort of being
given an answer by a bunch of computers
and you have to figure out the language
you have to figure out what the
computers are telling you oh yeah well I
mean I think there's the big data thing
is actually very very exciting I mean
for the application computers right
because there are discoveries to be made
there are correlations and patterns in
that data and they could be extremely
valuable to us we may learn all kinds of
things about our health based on huge
volumes of health data about how certain
behaviors affect certain diseases or
cause certain symptoms and so forth but
we don't really know that we munch over
all this data
so use your opportunity for that and
it's a form it's a form of discovery
right and make the comments that it's
not just looking at data a lot to be
done that way but notice so when HOD was
describing the algorithm the system has
the ability to be curious and to poke
whether it be randomly or directed and
we're seeing more and more work it's
called active learning and an active
sensing where the current understanding
or uncertainties define a gradient of
curiosity that causes the system to go
and touch the world and probe it and
sense and see action reaction so it's
sometimes it's not just dead data or the
it could be quite quite interesting in
large amounts but it's also interacting
with the world so I think having
machines ask questions that's really
interesting
machines asking this next interesting
question is the most the most
informative experiment to do and so
forth is really you know the kind of
future of science yeah I actually very
excited about that I mean we see that in
the case of Watson or where when it goes
to when you goes to answer a question
we'll see it gets it wrong or gets it
right but once the answer is valid it is
the correct answer
Watson go back and look at what it's
read and so you know what the right
answer appears in this passage why
didn't I score that passage high enough
why didn't I realize that this passage
or these set of passages actually
answers that question and it could look
at that and find where it failed and
that failure is represents an
opportunity to ask a question so for
example I didn't understand that if you
make something you produce it or if you
surround something you make cushion it
had I known that and Watson could
actually generate this and I known that
I would have scored this passage higher
so can ask if you surround something you
cushion it under what conditions you
know if this right if the thing doing
the surrounding is solved here and so it
could actually generate in fact this is
a active area research and also related
to active learning is based on their
failure as it goes out and it asks these
questions and I think what that suggests
is that what I think about what the
future holds is you know there's more
and more of this complementary
relationship between people and machines
and that through the interaction and
through collaboration through
cooperation machines can help make
humans smarter or more effective at what
they do and humans can make machines
smarter more effective at what they do
and you get this complimentary effect
that's the way I think we're gonna see
more and more that there's a long term
directions another notion that you're
hearing it's being alluded to in some
comments is the idea of endowing are
these these systems were building with
explicit knowledge that they're limited
and they're in the open more complex
world at the complicated real world is a
lot richer and more sophisticated and
has a lot more going on in it and it can
understand at the current time so it
actually understands it's a bounded or
limited
agent in the world and has techniques to
back off in question and get better and
better over time and potentially not
fail so dramatically like a fragile
brittle system that's over confidence to
know what doesn't know for example what
you know that it doesn't know a lot
about the world do you do you think that
there will always be those boundaries or
do you all think that there will be a
singularity well you know before I go to
the singularity I know I will you'd
already know I noted the word define
singularity because you can do better
than I yes right yeah
singularity there's a whole bunch of
people out there and when I don't think
any of us of them who are quite
convinced that in their lifetime
machines will get good enough and smart
enough that they can upload their
consciousness to the machine and
therefore will not die and to me that
says form of techno religion where you
get eternal life without the
inconvenience of having to believe in
God you just believe in super computers
so the this but the question is in the
long long term a thousand years from now
2,000 years from now what will our
relationship be with machines I think
it's impossible for us to know we can
already see a form of the way I
understand singularity is the question
of when do one point do machines become
smaller than people and can accelerate
their own development without people and
I think you know and even in this simple
pendulum case when we run this same
algorithm and other people run it on
data for which we do not know what is
going on we sometimes get beautiful
formula that explain and predict
everything that's in the system our form
these formula these models are simpler
than what is currently known and yet we
have no clue what they mean and so we
look at this and you know here the
machine came up with something it's it
knows something we don't know and we
just can't understand that and it's a
very
interesting feeling to have when the
machine kind of find discover something
that you don't understand that's true
but for most of most of what the
machines do there are still people
between the data and it in Watson's case
Watson isn't looking for sellers and
that's not a that's not people people
are still assigning the meaning right
the computer is still operating with
strictly symbols you use the word
curious but actually it's a program and
it was programmed to poke and you assign
that we were curious to that it's still
just a program that was told but I'm
also saying what curious to you so when
we use the word curious really we don't
know we're just cloaking a certain
behavior because it becomes you know
that this is it's human to
anthropomorphize and even from human to
machine even from human to human in some
sense you know I'm when I speak to you
I'm speaking to you and words and
phrases where I imagine you think like I
do if you don't I will so back to
understand a word I said back to face
question that people use this term
singularity in a variety of ways
including the original author of that
term Benguet and people like Ray
Kurzweil who later capitalized and
amplified on some of those ideas I think
people often view it in terms of more
generally in terms of potential
disruptions that might come our way
based on advances in machine
intelligence I think there will be a
number of these largely on the
beneficent wondrous side there already
are and it and and so but I think there
are things which have won in that pocket
different brands but this is a this is
an AI disruption I think it is but no
but but the but I think that there are
are some potential negative
possibilities we need to be proactive
about what are they well I mean I just I
can just give some examples of things we
might want to be certain this comes out
of a panel actually that I pulled
together
when I was crippled I president a couple
years ago the panel on long-term AI
futures we got about 25 people get
together and reflected Asilomar about
possibilities good and bad disruptive
possibilities on the negative side for
example in the shorter term this phrase
criminal AI came up the idea is think
about a really really advanced virus of
sorts computer virus someday that
can do machine learning about your
Facebook account and your iPhone or
Android or Windows mobile phone accounts
and to sit around watch your inbox for
two years before doing anything and we
can imagine ways that we can start
getting proactive about identity control
and cryptography and and come up with
methods that will protect us from these
potential futures where these
technologies are being used maliciously
in fact at this meeting we thought to
ourselves should we go as scientists and
create some of these example systems to
show the world what can be done by some
smart people who can do things like
automated decision-making learning from
from unstructured data about people for
example there's a whole other notion
about on the 8th on the on legal side
for example liability of autonomous
systems that are doing things that
weren't planned so a system is built for
X people think really deeply about how
it's going to behave in world's X X plus
plus and X plus plus enters world Y
create some damage who's liable and how
does liability work and how can we even
imbue our preferences and our deep you
know you know sort of humanity into
what's right in these kinds of systems
and so part of the panel deliberated
about that and the answers are not clear
just yet right let me ask you each of
you as a final question what about what
of the future of AI most inspires you
David I think this tremendous potential
we took we touched on many of them I
think and looking at large amounts of
data and doing and discovering things
that are important for advancing science
and for advancing society there's just a
wealth of knowledge out there and these
techniques can help bring access to it I
think what what impassioned me the most
though is this view that computers are
very very good a certain class of thing
and if we can get them to communicate
more effectively with humans we get this
we get this cooperation that I think is
going to benefit humanity in ways we
could only just start to imagine right
now so I'm excited about that well
besides the all the the applications
that we've discussed
advancing science and so forth what's
really most exciting to me is is it's a
new lens through which we can look at
these very deep questions age-old
questions what is consciousness what is
self-awareness what it is to be human
and for the first time we can look at
these questions in a very quantitative
algorithmic way rather than
philosophical it does strike me in
learning about your work that so much of
what you do involves questions about
about people you learn so much about
humans from what you do Eric what
inspires you the most about that
absolutely i resonate deeply with with
what HOD said it's this pursuit will
tell us incredible amounts about who we
are Who I am
from my perspective and I look forward
to learning more it's a black place for
me it's always what's always driven is
how is it that we work how is it that we
operate but at the same time I see that
artificial intelligence I'm not as
worried as you are about some of these
malicious concern is it that the the
systems we build become our partners and
increase our productivity as all
technology has over time and we will
reject the bad robots and will legislate
against them the world will build
systems which as we have over millennia
of Technology built technologies of it
largely we're all happy with gentlemen I
can't thank you enough both for
demystifying all of this and fascinating
us Eric rod HOD and David and Watson
thank you all so much
[Applause]
[Music]